aux quatre coins du pays la colère des
manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites cet organisée pour cette
dixième journée de mobilisation sa
détermination à ne jamais écouter les
Français elle conduit au chaos et donc
c'est là où il y a un problème il y a un
problème avec le président de la
République qui part dans un orgueil
démesuré
[Applaudissements]
si jamais on est directement gazé par du
gaz lacrymogène on peut avoir évidemment
plein de symptômes puisque ça va tout
simplement provoquer des brûlures avec
de l'irritation au niveau des yeux on
comprend assez facilement une production
de mucus et de larmes on a les yeux qui
coulent
si jamais les symptômes persistent de
brûlure oculaire au-delà d'une heure ou
deux je vous recommande d'aller voir un
ophtalmo puisqu'il y a un risque de
lésion au niveau de la conjonctive on
peut avoir des conjonctivites un ulcère
de la cornée voire même un glaucome
pardon
il faut prendre un mois un mois et demi
pour demander à une deux trois personnes
de faire de la médiation de la
conciliation d'aller voir les
différentes parties en disant vous les
quoi vous voulez quoi sur le travail
qu'elle s'en aille elle et sa réforme et
je crois que c'était
utile que des propositions soient faites
[Musique]
Laurent Berger l'a fait on a proposé une
nouvelle fois au gouvernement et surtout
au président de la République de
suspendre son projet et de nommer une
médiation la main tendue des syndicats
le président de la République doit la
prendre le gouvernement d'Elisabeth
borne il est cramé on n'a pas forcément
besoin de médiation pour se parler on
peut se parler directement le président
de la République l'a dit il est prêt à
recevoir l'intersyndical dès lors parce
que nous respectons nos institutions que
le Conseil constitutionnel se sera
prononcé sur la conformité de notre
texte de loi j'ai trouvé que Laurent
Berger avait été très loin en proposant
justement une pause une médiation et en
fait de maintenus que fait le
gouvernement quelle médiation avec un
Emmanuel Macron qui est complètement
fermé isolé dans son palais donc si vous
voulez le problème de fond c'est que que
s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
confondre casseurs et policiers
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
n'est pas un mot dans une question
d'actualité pour penser à tous ces
policiers ces gendarmes qui sont blessés
c'est une réforme qui est demandée par
l'Union européenne elle est en même
temps faite en Belgique en ce moment en
Espagne là-bas il le disent les
gouvernements ne s'en cachent pas c'est
Bruxelles qui demande parce que c'est
une privatisation déguisée pour
Blackrock et pour des fonds de pension
qui veulent récupérer ce marché ultra
juteux des retraites que s'est-il passé
à
gauche pour faire alliance avec Monsieur
Mélenchon qui les insultent qu'il est
vomit et qui finalement fait honte à
tous les électeurs de gauche à Lille
c'est parpaings ne sont pas destinés à
casser des vitres mes abâtir un mur et
ce devant le domicile d'une députée de
la majorité dans ces manifestants
scandent le nom
je veux également dénoncer avec force
les propos honteux de Monsieur Mélenchon
appelant à faire soigner les policiers
sans doute sans doute dans les camps de
rééducation qui existent dans les pays
dictatoriaux dont il vénère le modèle
qu'un ministre de l'Intérieur qui est
capable d'organiser un traquenard comme
celui qui a été mis en place à Sainte
Soline est absolument capable de toutes
les provocations à chacun d'entre nous
de faire preuve de sang-froid des
perquisitions menées dans cinq
établissements bancaires et financiers à
Paris elles interviennent dans le cadre
de 5 enquêtes ouvertes en 2021 sur des
soupçons de fraude fiscale à gravée
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le parquet
national financier et les banques
sociétés générales BNP Paribas Aixam
Natixis et HSBC sont soupçonnés d'un
schéma de fraude dit coucou sur cette
autoroute à Los Angeles un accident va
se produire imprévisible et
impressionnant
malchanceux le compte ducteur de la
citadine s'en sort bien semblait sur
graves la technique du coum c'est en
fait un aller-retour d'action entre un
actionnaire étranger et un intermédiaire
en l'occurrence une banque et c'est
aller-retour d'action et bien il permet
d'éviter de payer la taxe sur les
dividendes et l'argent économisé et bien
l'actionnaire étranger le partage avec
la banque